there is no final solution to how
you should shape yourself to the
environment or how you should shape the
environment to you there is no final way
i know this sounds paradoxical but we
always have to be perpetually hungry
for insight and for that adaptive
evolution
of our cognitive fittedness to the
environment
i've heard you say that people often
study what is most lacking in their
lives
is this true for you with regards to
awakening from a meaning crisis
yeah yeah it is uh that was uh when i
was in grad school i had a friend
and he said people went into psychology
often to study what they were lacking
and so i study relevance and meaning
and there's yeah there's definitely
existential truth um
i'm very much about trying to understand
uh how we are connected to ourselves to
each other to the world
um in ways that really matter to us and
to others
and um yeah that's because i very much
suffered my own personal version of a
meeting crisis
and this this task of sifting through
all of the available information to find
the relevant information has been
something
that i've needed to get get better at in
my own life um
so yeah in some ways i am
i i am the proverbial doctor trying to
cure his own disease yes
you professionalized the personal
challenge i mean
being honest from my side with this show
as well very much i took a big left turn
uh when i just before i started it and i
needed to find
answers i didn't even know what the
questions were but i just wanted
some sort of answers and i think uh
often you can actually end up bearing
pretty
pretty good fruits from that one of the
things that i've been really interested
in over the last couple of years has
been evolutionary psychology
and i find there to be an interesting
intersection between your work
and that given that we're biological
creatures
why do we need meaning structures like
it seems like our default setting as
humans
is so far away from what's optimal for
flourishing and
pursuing wisdom and meaning and flow
like why do we
have to do all this work like is it just
a mismatch with our genes
being there to make us effective and not
happy is it a weird quirk of
having a phenomenological experience of
being like a human what's going on
well there's a lot there um there's two
points i'd want to pick up on
there's one is i think there's a an
implicit standard
uh and i don't mean this in any
accusatory fashion but i think there's
an implicit standard behind your
question
um that i'd like to explicate and
perhaps challenge and then
we also face the issue that we are not
just biological creatures we're
called we're cultural creatures and and
that
that has an important um impact but
let's do the first one first
um why does meaning matter so much
well we we really tried in psychology
for 40 years to not deal with meaning it
was the
uh the behaviorist period and we thought
no what we could do is we could just
look at observable behavior
and and the you know the observable
properties of the stimulus and
just get those chains and you know and
we had watson and we had skinner and we
had a hundred literally a hundred
thousand of hours on working with the
rats
um and it turned out it doesn't work and
that's why there was this thing in the
50 called the cognitive revolution
because by and large you don't respond
to the physical properties of a stimulus
you respond to
well i'll use it vaguely here and then
we'll make it sharper as we go along you
respond to the meaning
so i can shout fire which is an acoustic
stimulus and you'll run from the room
you can see yellow flame totally
different stimulus
and you'll run from the room you can
smell the smoke totally different
stimulus and you run from the room
why are all the behaviors the same even
though the stimuli are so different in
their physical properties well because
they all mean the same thing to you but
here's the way to get at the meaning
they're all relevant to you in a
particular way
right of all the information available
to you right
and this is what you have to get right
from the beginning there is an
astronomically vast amount of
information available to you at all time
but with
both without in the environment and
within your long-term memory it's never
full
you never go nope can't take any more in
right and so
you have a vast amount and yet out of
all of that you have to do this
coordinated search between these two
and zero in on the relevant information
and what's happening
right for you or even the you know right
any other organism when in all those
instances of the fire
is you're grasping the relevant
information that it right
that you need in order to solve your
problems so you are framing
the environment in a particular way so i
want when i say
you're responding to the meaning i don't
want you to hear like semantic meaning i
don't want to
i'm not i'm not that's that's only one
species of what i'm talking about
we we do use words to zero in on our
attention but way before
and all the other organisms don't use
words we had to develop the intelligent
capacity
to pay attention in the right way and so
that ability is fundamentally
adaptive and and i don't mean just that
it makes us more adaptable what i mean
is
how it unfolds is in an adaptive process
so what i've proposed
um is and this is following up on the
work of evan thompson and work i've done
with other people
that our ability to do that is deeply
analogous to how
evolution works evolution works by
creating a large variation in the
population
right and then it puts selective
pressure and it windows it down and then
the variation comes out of that again
and it windows it down and you get right
this feedback cycle of reproduction with
change
i argue the theory that i've worked and
i'm talking about this at many levels
complex and recursive so don't hear it
overly simplistically
your brain is doing the same thing it's
opening up attention
for various possibilities that's why you
get distracted
but it's also slamming your attention in
to try
and select that's why you can get
fixated and you're constantly trying to
go between fixation and distraction
fixation and distraction and it's your
daily life and you say why can't i just
get to the perfect place
because there is no such thing
and that's the standard i want to
challenge right you can get an optimal
grip you can get an equilibrated state
for right here right now
in this environmental context but all
species go extinct
to pick up on the biological analogy
there is no final solution
to how you should shape yourself to the
environment or how you should shape the
environment to you there is no final
way so we we we have to
i know this sounds paradoxical but we
always have to be perpetually hungry
for insight and for right that that
adaptive evolution of our cognitive
fittedness
uh to the environment and so looking
and one of the things i think we need to
give up and this is where i get into
many arguments with a lot of people we
need to give up the idea of perfection
as what we're seeking that what we're
trying to do is get to some final state
where like why is it so difficult why
can't i just get to the final state
where everything works and i have that
optimal fit well you would have to be in
an
absolutely unchanging in all dimensions
environment
and you know where you don't absolutely
want to be you don't want to be in that
environment
so you're right you're basically
committed
to the fact that relevance realization
is an open-ended evolving process
and what i'm what i've been trying to do
in some of my work especially with the
help of chris master pietro
is to shift our sense of what is most
meaningful
what i call sacredness off of
a perfection and on to this this ongoing
evolution of your evolvability so that's
how i would
uh answer the first part the second part
is as i said this isn't just going on
biologically
right yeah so biology has shaped me so
i'm a particular size
so notice my hand is shaped because
parts of the environment are shaped
so that i can actually pick up parts of
those environment that are graspable to
me and i can make tools
right and so biology and evolution have
shaped me do you know what culture does
you know culture teaches me
how to use objects that it says shaped
so we
constantly fit together but culture
isn't standing still either
and then you as i just said your own
dynamic cognition is
constantly doing that too
so i think when you put it
that we're cultural beings
you have to see that we are operating
this this goes back to plato
we are operating at although it go also
in modern work by christopher honey
we're a great neuroscientist
we're we're working at many different
scales because adaptivity isn't a
one-shot deal
there's what's adaptive now there's
what's adaptive a little bit broader
contact
what's adaptive right and those
are in trade-off relationships right so
i'm wired to gorge on sugar and fat and
i eat the chocolate cake
but the problem is in this environment
chocolate cake is too available
and so i i better look for more
long-term goals of health
right etc and so
that fact that we exist at multiple
levels
that were cultural and that our
adaptivity is
an unfinished shop you can't finish it
this is not a finishable project
that's how you ha that's how i would
suggest you have to reframe it
i had this alan watts quote floating
around in my head for years
and i i can't get rid of it uh it says
if we are unduly absorbed in improving
our lives
we may forget all together how to live
them yes
yes yes and that process of being
and becoming the balance between being
tough enough on yourself to motivate
further action and
delicate and compassionate enough on
yourself to be able to have gratitude
for the things that you have done
this to me seems like being comfortable
with our sense of lacking wisdom
for people who desire wisdom seems to be
one of the most
difficult things to bear because it's
both
the the poison and the tonic
yeah well pharmacon pharmacy medicine
means both poison
and medicine the greek word it means
both um
so i mean socrates talks about this in
the symposium right
we are never wise we are always lovers
of wisdom if someone says they're wise
to you that's
often very good evidence that they
aren't um
so when you love something love is love
is this weird thing
like love is to recognize a lack
but also it gives you it starts to shape
you
in your seeking and part of the
the trick of love i think is taking that
lack
and right taking that gap that hole that
opening that vulnerability
and shaping it into receptivity
shaping it into sensitivity because
you're never going to grasp
wisdom but you can you can progressively
learn how to reshape
your lack into a sensitive space
that's better and better at receiving it
um and so
i think that the task of being a good
phyla
sophia philosopher a lover of wisdom
is exactly to go through that
transformation and and i
and i think that's consonant with many
of the ways we have to learn how to love
um the difficult thing and i find it
personally difficult i'm not speaking as
somebody who's on the other side of this
mountain
i'm still very much slogging in the
foothills trying to make my way up
uh but getting from you know love as
not sort of trying to hold on but hold
up
right um and and so that you can get
into this reciprocal opening with
something or someone
um i think that's a big part of this but
that's that's what i was meaning when i
was talking about an optimal grip this
is a term for marlo ponte
like whenever you when you don't you
don't think of yourself when you're
observing let's just do phys
visual perception you're not static you
move around so what you do is
you move closer to the object if you
want more detail you move farther out if
you want the bigger picture
and there's no perfect place to be
because you're constantly adjusting that
according to
well the needs that you have that are
changing and the environment that is
constantly changing in a similar way
if you'll allow me a bit of a stretch
you have to get an optimal grip on
yourself
and you have to get an optimal grip on
your lack of wisdom so that you
come in some sense to start to know
yourself
in the shaping of your love for wisdom
is that why you've got your tattoo
yeah this one you mean know thyself yeah
um yeah the one on my back is because
i want socrates constantly behind me um
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i mean i keep coming back to
that
again and again and again and
how often i'm going through something
around this right now where i found
ways in which unbeknownst to me i have
been
inertial i have not been
knowing myself so that i can open up
properly uh to the world yeah that
and so that keeps coming and and the
socratic sense of this right
know thyself isn't to recount your
autobiography we're all wonderful at
that
and and we glory in it and we how unique
my autobiography is and all that largely
bullshitty thing we do um but
more really it's almost like i say it's
not an autobiography i sometimes say
it's more like an operating manual
like how do i function how do i work
how am i stuck how am i ignorant and
even more important
can i get some sense often with the help
of others
of how i'm how i'm self-deceptive that's
what it means to
to know yourself from the socratic point
of view
if you were to write an ikea manual
you've just mentioned
the operating schedule there and i often
my first
ever brief um for the website that came
in touch with this podcast three years
ago was
life doesn't come with an operating
manual yeah if you were to do that ikea
put it together book what would the what
would the broad chapters
be what would it look like
the broad chapters would be learning
about the different ways in which we
learn the different ways we know
uh i mentioned the perspective on the
participatory like the procedural
and uh propositional as well
so learning the ways in which we are
intelligent learners
and then learning the ways in which the
very use of that intelligence
makes us vulnerable to self-deceptive
self-destructive behavior
um and then learning how to cultivate
an ecology of practices multi-level
recursive self-organization
checks and balancing and ecology of
practices
that can ameliorate the really really
complicated and often screwed ups
dynamical systems that we become
and then and then paying attention to
the dimensionality of that that this is
not just a cognitive task
it's you're not just coming into a
cognitive maturity
this is also and these are interwoven
we've separated them in our culture but
they're not separated in our brain
the way our you know emotional maturity
what does cognitive maturity look like
what is emotional maturity how do those
two forms of maturity
bump up against each other how do they
afford each other how do they support
each other how do they
interfere with each other um and also
existential
uh maturity um which has to do
with you know what what kind of
what i i hesitate to use this but what
kind of self do you have we're talking
about know thyself what kind of self do
you have
um what kind of roles is it capable of
how well coordinated are those roles
um how much do they conflict with each
other are how are you getting an optimal
grip between
this is from velman being sort of like
what he calls a wanton
like wanton behavior where you're just
acting on impulse or you're so
up here you're hamlet and you're
reflecting yourself to death and
everybody's dying around you
what kind like are you in between is
yourself getting you in between those
two
is it helping you aspire to a better
future self
is it like i said allowing you to assume
the roles that allow you not only to
function in a socially
or even morally acceptable way but in a
way that affords
the making of meaning the making of
those real connections
that's so yeah i think that's
that's those are the things i put in as
the chapters i reckon you could
construct a fairly good human from that
i reckon you could okay so looking at
the meaning crisis that we've got at the
moment i've spoken to a lot of people on
the show about
breakdowns of tradition and loss of
faith in religion and all of the kind of
obvious trope the people getting married
later people starting
the the challenges of women having to
actually make a choice between having a
career and having a family now like you
know that that is a difficult decision
for a woman to make
um moving forward
with regards to meaning right now what's
your sort of
sense because i know that the circles
that
you uh speak to are very very positive
the
uh david followers of the world the
jordan halls of the world well i mean
jordan john's not necessarily positive
he's he's like
he's sort of cataclysmic cataclysm uh
side of stuff but
it's people who understand what's
happening it's people who have a sense
of the direction that we need to go in
i've spent a lot of time dealing with 18
to 21 year olds on the front door of
nightclubs
i've watched a million a million of
those people go in and out
they're fantastic people they're
wonderful
they don't seem to be contemplating a
meaning crisis
how do we bridge a gap in a world of
tick tock and booty pictures and cat
funny cat videos of getting people to
think about
the thing which makes life worth living
okay well first of all it sounds like
you were in a different place because i
meet those 18 to 20 year olds
elsewhere of course because i'm a
university professor
and um the courses i teach that have to
do with
meaning and wisdom are overwhelmingly my
most popular courses
and my colleague jordan peterson when he
spoke about that
that's what helped rocket him to the
position so i think there's
good evidence that they there is hunger
and there's good
evidence that there's suffering remember
if you don't properly cultivate the gap
it can uh it can run awry we have you
know
that group even worldwide it's
ameliorated by
contextual things some countries often
countries that are
not as well off economically and
therefore tend to be more religious
but overall that group is going through
an increase in suicide
increased anxiety disorders depressive
disorders
um increase uh of
uh like related phenomena um
where for all of this connectivity
there's increased sense of loneliness
um which is really paradoxical uh given
what we keep getting told
by our culture um and you see a hunger
for
religious behavior in these people they
flock to superhero movies they dress up
in costumes
they play endless role-playing games
there's the what's
you know there's the virtual exodus the
escape into
virtuality in one way or another to try
and find
so yeah they may not be explicitly
saying i'm suffering from a meeting
crisis
but they're showing a lot of the signs
that they are and when you start to give
them just the first preliminary
vocabulary to start articulating it
this is what i've seen they get very
very excited about it uh um and very
like oh
right um in fact that that was one of
the most prevalent responses i got from
people
i still continue to get is like both in
my my classes and
in my series is you get like you
you gave me vocabulary to talk about
this stuff right
and sorry my phone thinks i'm trying to
talk to it
uh um yeah
and so i mean chris master pietro and i
we published an article
in the side view the journal where we
basically laid out i'm just giving you a
snippet there's a whole symptomology of
stuff that's happening
positive stuff too right there's
positive signs these people are way
more interested in mindfulness they're
taking up an ancient philosophical
practice stoicism
stoicism is going through a boom right
now right because they're looking for
ways
to cultivate wisdom and and so
yeah granted i won't i won't go into the
history but let me say there are
perennial problems we face
of self-deceptive self-destructive
behavior so we will perennially need
ecologies and practices that help us
deal with that and our culture isn't
offering wisdom
cultivation in any and that's why people
are so easily sucked in to
conspiratuality as jules evans talks
about it right because
they're looking for anything that will
give them the discernment
they're hungering for will give them
some sense of connection
and self-transcendence um and so
i do think that jordan jordan hall is
right
that we are going through a kind of
complexification
in our culture through the technology
and the communication
uh and globalization that is just
putting even more pressure
on the perennial problems it's like an
accelerant
on those problems um that have made it
uh very very much more
urgent for people so i mean there's
there's mounting evidence that instagram
and tick tock are really bad for your
mental health
right um and it's interesting when you
when because my son is in that well he's
just past the generation my older
son my younger son is just coming into
it my older son is like 25 my younger
son 16 so
they're bracketed around this group and
and
i see them wrestling with that
um a lot that this stuff
there's it's simultaneously very salient
and at the same time it's
not satisfying
i we spoke about this before we started
that i wonder how much
we can take of the good of social media
the things that you have enjoyed
and relish and cherish and the same for
myself without so much of the things
which make us feel
even in the moment not great and
afterwards retrospectively pretty
terrible
um and i've also read a lot of
existential risk over the last couple of
years which
fascinates me and terrifies me in equal
equal measure
and um when i combine that which is i
guess
civilization wide geologically wide
you know or interstellarly wide with
what's happening on an individual level
on a cultural level
locally in terms of people not binding
to i don't know who my next i don't know
my next-door neighbor's name
i don't know the person that lives next
door to me that wouldn't happen that
wouldn't have happened 20 years ago
um and is there is it a break point
that's coming is it the sort of thing
that's likely to require a big a big
wall to hit or is it the sort of thing
that's going to slow down
gradually
um is is civilization the kind of thing
that's going to slow around
gradually or this acceleration towards
what could be some very
very um maladaptive practices for humans
the way that we act the way that we
interact with each other
the things that we value yeah yeah um
so when i when i was going to do
awakening for the meeting crisis i mean
i was being encouraged by people the
videos here is a lot of people said
there's no way people are going to sit
through an hour
and do 50 of those and and they were
wrong
people did and then communities grew up
around it and continue
um so
i mean but on the other hand to your
point
i mean i won't get you know i won't get
like millions of views or something like
that that you might get for
a cat video or something like that right
um
so um i get what you i get what you're
saying and i'm not trying to be
dismissive
i do want to point out though that there
is evidence that people are capable
and they will seek out uh deeper more
long-term stuff
even in social media and so that means
there's at least a viable vehicle by
means of which we might do
what i've been suggesting which i have
this
sort of slogan and it's been put to
music where i talk about stealing the
culture
um i don't know
jordan hall and other people are better
at sort of
the economic
socio-political environmental factors
i do know something about complex
systems theory and the bronze age
collapse of civilization
and there are things that are genuinely
very worrying
about what we're doing right now um
so i think
there are too many uh
how do i say this we're not sounding
conspiratorial
there are but there are too many bad
faith actors in in
the social media world the the the
they're not even human beings many of
them are just algorithms
that like to manipulate us into a
narrative mode
like to excite us into outrage uh will
make us feel needy make us feel
insufficient uh inadequate because then
they can sell us
ideas and products and manipulate us and
and and we have increasing evidence that
this is
at work and increasing evidence that
it's what it does is it just takes those
self-deceptive patterns within
individuals
like individually and then just
accelerates them between
individuals collectively and then and
then people internalize that and you get
all of this crazy stuff happening uh
there's
so and and and i have and and i'm not
right wing or left wing on this but i
have no um
i know i i have no deep faith in the
corporate machinery and corporate
culture
i there are individuals i want to be
clear about that i've been approached by
businesses
um when one person said this very well
he said
you know i'm not just in the bottom line
i'm here for the top line
like i do want to make a profit but i
really believe in the meeting crisis and
i really
want to try and bring what you have to
say so there are individuals i don't
want to deny or or dismiss
them because they are i meet a lot of
them but i think they are the exception
that proves the rule
at the right that that by and large we
are
in a situation that's being accelerated
by social media
that is taking us further and further
away
from wisdom and and starving us more and
more for meaning
so what i mean by steel the culture is
this vehicle
is viable the way the early small cr and
this is the only
way this is the only dimension along
which i'm making the comparison
in which the you know the early
christian communities
took shape and started creating a
different way in which people could be
with each other
different sense of what it was to be a
self i mean
augustine invents the sense of self the
interior self that we now think is
natural
he right you can see kerry's book on it
is beautiful
right um just we'll just brilliantly
argue
so christians are creating a new sense
of self a new sense of community
a new whole way of seeing and being and
they're doing it
outside the huge manipulative machinery
of the roman empire until eventually
right as the roman empire starts to
weaken
that culture takes over the empire still
falls
but that culture then goes on and
becomes christendom which of course then
had its own problems
what and because again there is no final
state there is no final solution
so i think the solution is to try and
steal the culture
and that's a long-term intergenerational
project and that's where the work of
zach stein about
we've got to bring back education as a
long-term intergenerational project
i think is really really pertinent so
that's what i'm that's what i'm trying
to do i'm trying to do something
analogous
um to and i don't mean to set myself up
in in any other way
but i'm trying to do something sort of
analogous to saint paul and
and to augustine
because i i don't think we can
so when i was growing up and i will do
it maybe you guys
still know it there was a rock group
called the police
sting came out of that right and they
have spirits in the material world which
is a really
gnostic song and they have the line in
there there is no political solution
and i know people people get angry at me
when i say this but i don't think there
is a political solution
i think what we need is a cultural
solution and that's
much more difficult to generate
and i don't think the machinery of the
state or the machinery of the market
is going to be particularly helpful for
that project
i think i agree uh i mentioned to you
before we started that i often get drawn
into conversations around
politics and sort of collectivist so i i
someone commented the other day saying
that they couldn't work out my political
standing and i replied and just said
good
like that's yeah i i don't i don't want
to be someone who leads with his
group think ideology belief structure
first
um getting back to the the personal
getting back to the individual
relevance realization is a term that
you've popularized yeah can you take us
through that and
why it can cause us problems and also
liberation
oh well i was mentioning it earlier and
so let's
i was talking about this fact you know
that the brain is doing this process
analogous to evolution
right where remember the way your
attention is widening out and getting
distracted introducing variation
right and then it zeroes in and then
sometimes when you get sort of you you
think you've got a problem framed
um and then you reel up and you get an
insight you go oh
right i'm looking at it the exact wrong
way i'm finding the and here's what i
want to say
i'm finding the wrong thing salient i
wasn't actually picking up on the
relevant information that's an insight
so this process
is like evolution it's self organizing
self cred self correcting
insight is your most common experience
when you chain a bunch of insights
together and
that right you get the flow experience
and people find that optimal
uh so as i said you like and
this is the core thing the core
difficulty facing us to try to make ai
right making ai they can do great logic
and math we've been able to do that for
decades
decades getting an ai
that can zero in on the relevant
information to solve a problem at hand
that's the hard problem it's often
called the frame problem
in artificial intelligence and yet
you're doing it right now
like think about how so much is obvious
to you
and here's the thing you can rely on in
your everyday life
things being obvious to you but my job
as a scientist is i can't rely on that i
have to try and explain
how you do that how is it that it's just
obvious to you uh right that when i'm
saying you
you know that i'm talking to you right
now and but also you wanna
you have a sense that it could apply to
people in general and you're following
up on some implications and not others
and you're you're you're paying
attention to everything i say
but not literally everything i like how
you're doing
all of that and what associations you're
calling to mind
now but the problem with that the
problem with that
is that zeroing in so
this is not what you're doing you're not
your brain isn't checking all of the
information to see if it's relevant
so is that no is that no
no because that would take the rest of
the history of the universe
so this is like a zen cohen somehow
you're intelligently ignoring most of
the information
overwhelmingly most of this vast amount
of information
and zeroing in you can't do it perfectly
for reasons i've already
discussed but you're really really good
at it but here's the thing
here's the thing that focusing of your
attention
and ignoring information
that makes you so adaptive also means
your your attention is biased
that you sometimes ignore things you
shouldn't ignore
so i go into a place where well people
used to do this but then phones took
this away so this is now disappearing as
a death ring
but until phones this used to be a big
deal people would go into a dark place
where they knew flammable glass was
dispersed
and they needed light so they would
strike a match
because the way they wanted light and
that's relevant and they didn't pay
attention to what they thought was an
irrelevant side effect
because it normally is which is the heat
of the match but in that situation it
turned out to be relevant and they blow
themselves up
so you have part of wisdom
is learning how to improve that
relevance realization
so that it is better and better at being
self-corrective
better and better at being insightful so
that when you have misframed things
because you always have to frame things
you always have to frame things that's
relevance realization
but wisdom is to enhance that so that
you get
better at being more insightful and
cutting through
ways in which you might be potentially
misframing the situation
upon hearing your work because i came to
you
after going through the rationalist
movement
and i hear echoes i don't really
have the i'm not eliader yukowski's
toenail
um but i hear things like bayesian
updating or like uh
becoming a bayesian agent or uh mental
models the mental modeling view of the
world and how we perceive our mental
model rather than we actually perceive
what's going on in reality
sure sure where how much
cohesion is there here does it sort of
move away from the rationalist movement
is the rationalist movement
some of the things that you have come
upon under different names
sure yep so i mean there's one level
at which the the version of the bayesian
stuff that i'm interested in is called
predictive processing models
and i'm actually working with two other
people right now uh
mark miller and brett anderson to try
and integrate relevance realization
theory
with predictive processing because we
think they need each other um and so at
the scientific level
um that's work that's going on right now
and i hope it will be done this year and
hopefully published
this year and i think this could be
maybe the last sort of big thing i do in
my career
um i mean my academic career because i'm
getting old um
but at the level
at which it's taken into popular culture
i mean
you can't be bayesian um be like
so if you were to try to be bayesian and
gilbert harmon made this point a long
time ago in the 80s in a book called
change in view if you tried to be
bayesian right
you would you that's computationally
intractable you'd be call it
combinatorially explosive you can't do
it
okay so what we see
organisms doing is they're bayesian with
respect to what they find salient or
relevant which
then just brings back the question about
okay how do you
do that that's why you can really piss
off a person
from the predictive processing model you
ask them but
which model what do you choose to model
and then they'll they'll do a circular
thing that which turns out to be most
adaptive
which is a teleological explanation yeah
but how do i build a machine that will
do that
right i get that that's how it works but
how do i build a machine that would do
that how do i update the model how do i
bring insight into the
model how do i compare models of
different scale right
and and and so there's all of that
and i suppose that's points to the
deeper issue which is
we have to overly simplistic a model of
rationality to my mind
because we have these different ways of
knowing and we have
we have over limited the model of
rationality
to the logical right implication
relations between propositions
we've limited rationality to inference
to inference management
now that's an important part of
rationality because changing your
abilities changes your behavior
but that that is only a small sliver of
what makes you a cognitive agent
your procedural knowledge you're knowing
how to do things your skills
that's a big part uh and you can be
there's ways in which you can be
rational or irrational in that
because you can you can transfer a skill
inappropriately
right and and people you we catch people
doing that all the time
and it's like no no that's not the right
skill here right
you can be perspectivally right
irrational you can be totally logical
with a completely fixated egocentrism
and if you don't know how to transform
your perspectival knowing
you're going to suffer from a kind of
self-deceptive behavior
same thing with the participatory
knowing if you're not paying attention
to
the relationship between the age and
arena relationship that can spiral
downward into addiction
right so we have to see that for all the
kinds of knowing
there are perennial and profound
patterns of self-deceptive
self-destructive behavior
and so rationality is any kind of
systematic
and reliable and systemic set of
practices
for ameliorating our self-deceptive
behavior so it's not
just the logical education of our
inference machinery
it's also the education of our
procedural abilities our perspectival
ability
so for example under my definition
mindfulness is a form of rationality
because mindfulness has to do with
training attention so you get better
skills that's procedural so your
perspectival knowing
is more optimally and reliably
functioning
and so we have many rationalities
and then we have sort of a meta
rationality of coordinating them
together so that they optimally function
together
so we have sort of a self-transcending
rationality of rationalities that's what
i think wisdom is
can we go through your four types of
knowing
sure and understand how uh explain how
the hierarchy of those fits together
so the one we're most familiar with as i
said is propositional knowing this is
the knowing
that is the vehicle of it is believe our
propositions
so i know that cats are mammals and by i
either believe it
or i don't believe it and then the
normativity of that is
truth or falsity that's my sense of
realness and there's a form of memory
that goes with that it's called semantic
memory this is where you know that cats
are mammals
right right um but
there's procedural knowing this is
knowing how to do something
this is knowing how to catch a ball
there's knowing how to ride a bike this
is knowing how to kiss somebody that you
love and
knowing how to do it depending on what
kind of love you have for them
right and so that is
that's not about beliefs it's about
skills you don't have a you don't when
you're done that you don't have a theory
you have expertise
and it's not about true or falsity it's
about power
it's about how apt your skill is how
powerful
it can intervene we have different
senses of realness yes we have the
conviction of truth
but we also have this sense of power is
another sense of realness
and of course we have a different kind
of memory that goes with that and it's
it's brilliantly in psychology called
procedural memory because it gives
right then we have perspectival knowing
this is knowing what it's like to be
here now
in this state of mind
i know what it's like to for me to be me
here now
in a sober reflective state of mind this
is what it's like this is what my
salience landscape is like
when i so i know what it's like to be
here now
in this state of mind and that gives me
it doesn't give me a theory
doesn't even give me skills it gives me
the situational awareness
that tells me which skills i should
apply or acquire
but that's dependent on me ultimately
being oh i didn't give you the sense of
realness there the sense of realness is
we know this from vr work virtual
reality it's the sense of presence
it's the sense of being in the game
right like oh i'm really present and
that's why we crave for that because
it's it's what gives us our sense of
realness
right and it's not the same thing as
verism limited you can get
that sense of presence in a game like
tetris that has very little to do with
how the world is really
set up um it has more to do with again
this optimal gripping thing i was
talking about earlier
below the perspectival like if i'm going
to have situational awareness i have to
be fitted to my environment there have
to be affordances
that's the level of the participatory
knowing that's the level at which
evolutionary biology cultural history
and the dynamics of my ongoing cognition
are shaping my identity shaping the
identity of things
so that they fit together in an adaptive
manner
so what's most ancient and most
fundamental ontologically
is the participatory because if you
don't have that the other ones can't
work
and then once we get beings that
plausibly have consciousness you have
perspectival
and procedural right with us
we get this weird thing where i can make
noises come out of my face hold and it
creates thoughts in your mind
we get language and we have to justify
statements and we get justification
systems as greg enriquez says
around propositions and we get we get
really fixated on that
as that's where we are and that's where
all
knowing is and that's where all
reasoning is and that and
and this of course this leads to
something you mentioned earlier
you get the pseudo-religion of ideology
you get that
what i need is a set of propositions and
i have to be really clear on what all
those prophets and what i believe
and what my belief system is um
and the problem with ideology and belief
systems and people who
um want to understand everything just as
political
is and this is why precisely why it's
pseudo religious is it ignores
the procedural the perspectival and the
participatory
and if you pay attention to traditional
religions until maybe the protestant
reformation
they cared a lot more about those other
ps than they did about the propositions
right they cared much much more
about knowing how and knowing what it's
like to be
and right and so the participatory
all right that gives you affordances
gives you a sense of belonging
when it goes wrong you can fall into
addiction and
like i said that that has its own kind
of memory
perspectival knowing has episodic memory
this is your ability to remember
situations in
like a scene and participatory knowing
has that weird sense of memory we don't
even
sometimes forget that it's a sense of
memory the sense of memory we call
our sense of self our sense of identity
and that also is in a different place in
your brain and right
so those are all the kinds of knowing
the relationships they have with each
other
the the normative standards they're
judged by their results the vehicles
that they operate in
um and the different kinds of memory and
so
like you have to think about all the
different ways in which we're connecting
to the world
and most of the meaning making machinery
is not at the propositional level it's
at the level of the other three
right now in 2021
we're being championed for knowledge
workers remote working from anywhere on
the planet via zoom
yeah the cerebral scientific rationalist
utilitarian revolution
is this why we're being taken out of the
embodied knowledge and up into the brain
while we've been doing it uh you know
we've been doing it i mean for a very
long time
uh when we when for example when
christianity became increasingly
creedally oriented and that right then
that doesn't happen for like the first
four centuries
in which the creed and and this is this
is even paradoxical
credo i believe originally meant like i
give my heart to believe in
i love it rather than i believe it right
but we've lost that we've lost now we
think of belief as
assertion right um and then it gets
really increased by the protestant
reformation
cartesian so we've had a long history
that's tutored us
the nominalism of the middle ages like i
go into this series
but the scientific revolution the
protestant reformation
the the movement towards written
contract as the way in which we bind
ourselves together in a society
we have increasingly um we have
increasingly
seen propositions as the place in which
we live and i'll uh i'll
quote the bible but and i don't mean to
be sacrilegious
in which we live and move and have our
being in these propositions
um and i think you're right i think
the the the printed word and the textual
word
um are really emphasizing that um even
more so
the problem the zoom brings the
possibility of a bit more
of the perspectival but it's limited not
too much of the procedural except
sort of conversational skills um
i'm trying to work out a way in which we
can bring in
more of the perspectival more much more
of the participatory
that's what i'm involved in this project
the deal logos project
and really broaden the set of skills we
we should be bringing
to this medium so that we can offer an
alternative to left and right wing
um totalitarian approaches you know
and i don't mean totalitarian just in a
governmental sense i mean that
that propositional knowing that that
kind of tyranny of the propositional way
of knowing
can be challenged
i know that you're a fan of tai chi and
for a long time while i was a
teenager i practiced i taught i did a
lot of kung fu for the same thing
and there was something there first off
there's a fondness
when i look back like i really really
enjoy that memory every time i drive
past the church that we did it in back
home
it gives me a very unique sense that i
don't think i've really got from much
else
um but there was a particular type of
knowing
in that a sense that i don't really get
i don't get it from mindfulness
i don't get it from sitting i don't get
it i don't get it from yoga
actually now i find that i don't get get
it from that either but there was
something to do with
the sort of movements the connection
from from from body to brain
um totally totally yeah i mean so
i think what's really cool about tai chi
chuan is precisely because
um it goes into the some of the nuts and
bolts of the operating manual
um so this is a story about me i was in
grad school
and uh and i had i sort of given up on
academic philosophy as a place where you
cultivate wisdom i continued to do it
because i
i liked the meta science and
metacultural critique skills it was
giving me
um and then of course it fed into the
cognitive science in a powerful way
but i've been i've taken up tai chi
because i thought well
there was a it was actually a school
nearby and i could do
the past the meditation meta meta
contemplation and tai chi choi and so
that's where i'll go to cultivate wisdom
and i was doing that
and it was particularly the tai chi and
i remember my friends coming to me after
i'd been doing it for a couple years and
saying what's going on with you
and i thought oh crap because when
you're in grad school you're always
worried that you've done something wrong
right
um and it's what do you mean what do you
mean and they said you're
you're different you you think
differently you're more and
this is a wonderful wonderful way one
wonderful evidence of
exactation you're more balanced you're
more flexible
right and you're thinking and i hadn't
even realized it i've just been doing it
like you said
like for you i enjoyed it but this
transformation had been percolating up
um and to me and there's other other
evidence but that's to give anecdotal
evidence right
that tai chi chuan is designed to work
at the
like it starts out like at the sort of
procedural level you're learning
skills but it starts to get into the
perspectival level you realize the
skills start to shift the way you're
seeing things
right and then and that's and the
language for this the
the the connection between the skills
and the scenes is this language around
chi
and then it gets even deeper translating
it as energy is a really bad translation
right uh and right and then and then it
drops to the participatory level you
start to become
a different agent right within a
different arena
and i think when you can then do the
thing that tai chi does
in those three when you can get into the
flow state
in something that's aligning and
enhancing the procedural the perspective
of the participatory
in a way that seems to transfer out and
be exacted out into multiple domains in
your life
of course you would love that of course
you would love that
in fact isn't that precisely the kind of
practice you should love
it's difficult not to and it makes me
every time that i think about it it
makes me sort of
wistful it's like a hunger it's like a
it's the same way i imagine a smoking
craving must be for so i've never smoked
but i imagine it must be the same way
that a craving for nicotine works
um that's that hunger we were talking
about earlier that's that lack
that's that hunger for connection i call
that religio
and and because religio originally meant
to bind together so that things belong
together
but of course it's one of the purported
etymologies for the word religion
right but it's that hunger and something
shaped it for you for a while and it
shaped it from just being a hunger
into being a receptivity a potential for
connectivity
sorry i'm being presumptuous but i'm
trying to suggest you that
i think that's what what the what the
wistfulness is for us is
that hunger was shaped into a
receptivity that enhanced the religio
enhanced that connectedness that's at
the foundation of our cognitive agency
let's say that there's some normal
person like me
who's listening who wants practices to
cultivate
their meaning on a daily basis i know
that you have i wouldn't go as far as to
call it a prescription but some perhaps
some best practice practices
of how you try and ensure that it
happens in yourself how can you
instantiate this with
with daily work so
you need like i said you need an ecology
of practices you need
you need because each practice has
strengths and weaknesses and you have to
send them into complementary
relationships with each other
um so for example you should
uh you should have a mindfulness
practice that will shut off the
inferential processing to enhance the
insight processing
but you need it you need active
open-mindedness which is the odd which
is the other practice
the saw it dampens down the insight
machinery you say why would i want to
dampen down the insight machinery
remember what i said earlier the thing
that makes you adaptive also makes you
subject to maladaptive
you know what makes you jump to
conclusions inappropriately when you're
thinking in an inferential fashion
it's that same insight machinery so
sometimes
you need to shut off the inferential
machinery because you need insight
but sometimes you need to dampen down
the insight machinery
so you you run your more careful
argument
careful inference you don't jump to
conclusions inappropriately
so you have to cultivate both
mindfulness for the insight
and active open-mindedness for the
better inference and then they
and then they have to constantly do
opponent processing push and pull on
each other
in a dynamically self-organizing fashion
you should
definitely uh you need to take up
a a psychophysical practice like tai chi
chuan and yoga
that will put you more readily into
the flow state that's quantitative but
qualitatively
so you flow more but you also want to
flow better what i mean by flow better
learn how to flow in a way that
is acceptable transferable in an
adaptive manner
to many different domains in your life
you need to get a dialogical practice
like we are doing right now because
we primarily learn how to transcend
ourselves through internalizing other
people's
viewpoints on our viewpoint that's how
kids do it
and that's how adults continue to do it
and we need to bring back practices that
have us not only communicating
like all of this wonderful technology
but communing
which right it's a like we can we can
we can together generate reciprocal
religio
such that we get better at
connecting to what is more real we can
what if we can we can bring flow into
how we communicate with others
right and so you need practices like
that you need practices
drawn from stoicism to help you overcome
weight not just stoicism any practices
that help you
understand like i said
earlier the different kinds of maturity
cognitive maturity
emotional maturity existential maturity
um find out ways in which you're stuck
emotionally stuck existentially not just
ways you would europe
ways of course in which you're stuck
cognitively um
and so you need you need practices of
what i call serious play
we used to have ritual there's a reason
why cultures across history and
and and cultural context have ritual
because you have to engage in serious
play in order to that's why
play is such a developmental necessity
for
all intelligent mammals and especially
for human beings
we have trivialized play we have made it
just entertainment
just for pleasure you've forgotten and
that's what ritual used to be
and i don't mean like neurotic ritual
that's a misuse of the word ritual that
means
a a a routine that you can't get out of
a compulsive routine i'm not talking
about
i'm talking about what we used to do
right when we would engage in ritual tai
chi chuan practically
properly practiced is a ritual it is a
form of serious play
in which you can taste and play with
other identities
other perspectives other ways of seeing
and being so you can make a more
appropriate and
dare i say rational choice of whether or
not you want to undertake
that aspirational journey towards that
different self in a different world
people go to therapy because they don't
know how to seriously play
because because that's what therapy is
people want to be what
people know propositionally i want to be
over there
i want i want to be i want this is how i
want to be and they'll give you a great
propositional description
and this is the world i want to be
living in and i can't get there i don't
know i don't know how
i don't know what it would feel like i
don't know how to be
notice all the other p's that are
missing they know that but they don't
know how they don't know what it would
be like they don't know how to be
that kind of person so they have to
engage in the serious place so they can
taste
that and decide in that liminal space
am i going to commit to that
so we you need practices of
ritual um and
um and what that looks like i mean maybe
that's journaling for you
uh maybe it's philosophical maybe it's a
joint practice with other people
like i've got some videos out there
philosophical
uh fellowship how do you get together
read a philosophical text and then
don't read it for information read it
for communication and communing
and trying to almost make present it's
almost like a secular seance
the the perspective of the author of
that text so that you can
come into a perspectival awareness of
what it might it might taste like to be
wiser than you are
there's all kinds of things that you can
do if you're interested in that i mean i
did a
you know when kovitz started i i did a
live stream and we we recorded it all on
you know meditating with genre of aiki
and then contemplative practices and
some movement practices
and then wisdom practices drawn from the
epicurean tradition the stoic tradition
the neoplatonic tradition that's all
there that's all there for people who
want to make use of it all on your
youtube channel yep all on my youtube
channel
that will be linked in the show notes
below of course
yep and there's also the whole voices
with raviki series
that i've been doing where i'm trying to
figure out and i'm also you know writing
on it and trying to
writing articles and books on it with
other people but i'm trying to figure
out because what's emerging now are all
these dialogical practices
people are trying to figure out like
socrates
how do i get into authentic dialogue
what i call via logos and and so voices
with viveki is
a bunch of instances of me trying to
figure that out
exemplify it talk about it live it
reflect on it explicate it exemplify it
again
like that's what that whole series is
all about
speaking personally and i think i'm
probably a pretty good avatar for the
people that are listening
as well um it it makes me feel almost a
little bit uncomfortable
how much i have put the
cerebral the rational the utilitarian on
a pedestal
um and it's only i [ __ ] you know within
the last
year half year six months that i've even
started to put the word sacred back into
my vocabulary
right um and
it's not just it it's i unless i'm even
more of a freak than i thought
it's not just me it's no it's not this
is not
this profane we had this example
think about how many people still wear
their shoes in their bedroom the shoes
that they've been outside in
in their bedroom in which society would
that be allowed
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i know that it's
kind of like a silly example but
it it sort of explains what i mean the
transactional transient nature of sex
the
pick pick your example and um
this is me speaking from as somebody who
wants
growth who feels that growth in all
directions is a good idea um
and i can see in myself some huge lacks
l-a-c-k-s um yeah
yeah i i feel like having been exposed
to your work
it reminded me and sort of opened my
eyes to just how much work there is for
me to do
upon doing a podcast where you speak to
people for you there's nearly a thousand
hours of me talking on the internet
available now
so i've spent an awful lot of time
developing
up here um but it's been at
the cost of various other types of
knowing
various other types of practice as well
the practices that i've been drawn to
and maybe
a lot of the people that are listening
to have been ones that have facilitated
my cognition
they've been ones that have allowed me
to perform better within the arena of
play
of cognition yes
yes yeah you me brother both
right my besetting sin
is i tend to bring in
my capacities for rational argumentation
and scientific theorizing into places
where they do not properly belong
uh that is one of the things that i have
to pay very careful attention to it's
one of the proclivities for
self-deception
and the mistreatment of others that i
have to
i have to pay a lot of attention to so i
totally i totally get what you're saying
i'm not accusing you of anything i'm
just
sharing um and so
i think and what i mean i'm doing
scientific
work on this with people like jennifer
steller and michelle ferrari
and johnson kim and brian ostoffen on
awe
we're like aw and so
remember how insight is like opening up
to a frame well
and this is the difference between
curiosity and wonder curiosity is when
you're trying to fill a hole in your
knowledge
wonder is when you're willing to call
your world and yourself more into
question
that's why socrates said wisdom begins
in wonder and then when you if you push
it a little bit farther you get awe
and there's a reason why we like awe
because
that is where we are really opening
ourselves up
to this non-propositional
transformation that we've been talking
about they see oz and experience
and experiences have to be cultivated by
virtue
and we have lost the virtue that gets us
to appropriately
grip the ah experience what do you mean
well so all right
so let's just get a sorry a quick
aristotelian thing
about right uh i'm trying to cultivate
my character
um and so there are things in my
environment that are fearful
and i i right and but my response can be
uh can be wrong in in access or deficit
i can i i can show i can i can be
overwhelmed too easily by my fear and i
become a coward uh
but i can then right not not pay enough
attention to the reality of fear
what fear is trying to get me to see and
then i become a fool
and i become an impulsive risk-taking
idiot right and i harm noting
not only myself but others and so what i
do is i create these sort of
like again this opponent processing i
create habits that
make me confront me fear more sort of
open up the variation you can hear the
evolutionary language here
and then i create counter habits that
parent down and put selective pressure
on it and
but and by doing that i sort of steer
between these two until i get
better and better at getting an optimal
grip on
how fear is relating me to the
environment is that okay
did that make sense yeah so think of awe
and
and and if you push off too far it
starts to create a kind of fear
or so think of all like that you you're
opening yourself up there's a sense of
exposure
the sense of self gets small right so
how how do you properly steer awe
so that right you don't
you don't overwhelm people or get them
blown away
or get them hardened or traumatized
or on the other hand how do you how do
you coax them out of their comfort zone
so they just want to stay home and never
never leave home like luke skywalker
right do you have to blow their home
apart in order to do that right
so woodruff talks about this he talks
about
the virtue by which we appropriately
relate to the what awe is showing us
about the environment and he calls that
virtue to reverence
see reverence is relevance that
right so when you look at the things
that
create meaning in life many people think
it's a sense of purpose
a sense of purpose is one of the things
but it's not the most important thing
that's kind of like that's a little bit
too market-oriented right
um the the other things that make you
feel connected religio have that sense
of meaning in life
are a sense of intelligibility like this
has to make sense
i have to be zeroing on the relevant
things in the relevant way
right significance or depth it has to be
real
it has to be real i have to be able to
discern the real patterns from
the illusory patterns but you know what
really makes a difference to meaning in
life
it's mattering that's what susan wolf
talks about that sense of being
connected to something larger than
yourself
something that has a value and a reality
beyond your egocentric perspective
reverence is the sense of mattering
it's the sense of being connected to
something not because of how
it is important to your egocentrism but
of how you are important to
it about how you are plugged into
something bigger than yourself
that is going on and that's and i think
reverence reverence is what helps
tutor ah into a sense of the sacred
a lot of the words that you use in your
work
have been things that i've come upon
over the last year
and orr is certainly one of them i
whenever whenever i hear the word or i
always think about the night sky
you know big yes open expanse making you
feel small and insignificant and framing
your problems and
your finite capacity
framed with infinite complexity that you
can see above yes
beautifully said beautifully said um
i i did i had this tweet a while ago
saying you were a finite creature
surrounded by infinite complexity
of course you're going to be scared yes
um yes but what ah says is
again you can shape that lack you can
shape that fear
into a receptivity because it also means
that you're a creature
that can as schlegel put it we are
finite beings
longing for the infinite rights so
you can shape that that exposure that
hole that vulnerability
it's not easy i'm not claiming to be a
master of it by any means
but i have some sense of this that you
can shape that
so that yeah the fear is more
awe and it's more of a sense of how
the infinite affords you
it affords you the escape
from the prison walls of your own ego
and that sometimes when our ego
is being diminished that's death
but sometimes when our ego is being
diminished that's overcoming
the prison of our egocentrism i mean
when we moved from transient sex
to the really difficult
commitment to being in love with
somebody and really reciprocally opening
with them
um because it's it's hard and it hurts
right like it it's hard and it hurts
again
again right and and if you're just in
egocentric mode you'll just become
afraid of that and then you close up and
you just have
the transient sex but if you're capable
of
if those little holes of grief become
apertures through which you see beyond
yourself
and for a moment you have some awe about
wow
that person really does transcend my
grasp of them
that's what keeps you going and that's
what makes that's what takes you into
the depths of yourself and other people
in reality
and then again what else do you want
i don't know i i i really do think that
the common thread between a lot of your
work
um is a lot of things that i've been
thinking about recently and i think
that's one of the reasons that
it does have a sense of dread is perhaps
to
uh significance significance in the same
way is when you stand on the edge of
a cliff and you look down that's that's
the sort of sense that i get
and i hope that a lot of the audience
will be being introduced to you for the
first time some not
but a lot certainly for the first time
um
you have been talking about we i want to
bring up after socrates in a in a moment
one of the one of the um allegories that
plato's allegory of the cave which i was
taught about only only again within the
last year by a friend called jordan you
know i'd heard it before but i didn't
understand its significance
for people who are seeking
whatever we want to call it truth wisdom
actualization transcendence
growth whatever term it is that you want
to give yourself um you are inevitably
going to put yourself out
on a limb and you are a participatory
being you are
someone who wants to be wanted liked
accepted for
being a part of the group but inevitably
you've changed
now your friends thankfully said you're
balanced you seem more balanced
but equally people can be very very
unhappy at seeing friends change and
grow because it often highlights their
lack of change and their lack of growth
what would you say to people who have a
desire to make change in their life
but don't necessarily have that
support that community and they've got
that fear of of the
um being ostracized for doing it
first of all um
i want to expect deep compassion because
that has
you said i studied what i lacked um
and so yes um
when you when you undertake this
um and again this isn't like you know uh
you know a slot machine put the
thing in and pull the lever or something
like that but um
when you undertake this kind of journey
you yeah you will lose
you will lose relationships i don't
wanna i don't wanna mince that at all
i have i have
a marriage right it's and that's not to
make myself heroic
i also did shitty things that caused the
demise okay
um i don't wanna i don't wanna avoid
responsibility but
it's fair to say that was also a factor
i can say that i think honestly
and i think the person who was involved
would say that honestly too
um so and you know you can uh and and
and that's a difficult thing we
sometimes face in our relationships when
we realize
that you know there's a significant
significant differential and our growth
arcs
like and that can be extremely and i
think that's not recognized enough as a
problem
in our relationships and the problem is
because of the decadent romanticism of
our culture
we basically try to turn our romantic
relationships into a religion
uh and so we put tremendous pressure on
them and they they really can't bear it
they really can't bear it and we should
stop doing that we need other things
um and i'm guilty of that too i like
again i'm guilty of that too
um i do it i've done it recently and
it's been problematic and
i have to take a step back and go oh
crap i'm doing that i speak about this
and
here i am doing it right and so
all of this stuff is going to
it's yeah you're going to lose
relationships
um but what seems to be the case
is you will
you will gain a and i'm playing on this
word i want it to mean both meanings
you will gain virtuosity and that
virtuosity
will allow you to discern
but also attract to you kind of people
who are also
seeking virtuosity um
and so different kinds of relationships
will become available
um to you and it takes
and and and i'm sorry
it takes longer than the lifetime of a
movie that's the problem with movies
we feel wonderful because it only takes
two hours for things to be resolved
and this can be years in the making um
but you will also find friendship where
you might not have found it before you
might find
you might you might befriend your body
and your mind
in a way you haven't before i have a
wooden sword i do tai chi with and i
have befriended that
i have learned how to more deeply defend
socrates
and spinoza um
so some of their friendships will be
ones that
might not be sort of with um
living people but they'll nevertheless
be living relationships for
you and that is not paradoxical or
self-contradictory
and then hopefully
again this is not deterministic but it
does increase the probability
that you will more likely come into
the kind of relationship um
that is supportive of you cultivating
wisdom i think that's one of the
that's one of the defining differences
between buddies and friends
we call a lot of people our friends but
they're not they're our buddies
a buddy is somebody you enjoy doing
something with and you should have
buddies
that's good that's why we have this term
a friend is somebody
that is committed to you becoming wiser
and you are committed to them becoming
wiser and that's a different thing
entirely
and you will increase your chance of
real friendship
so you might find again i can't promise
you there isn't an algorithm here
a magical formula but i i have found and
i've seen it in others that you get a
trade-off
you know the quantity of relationships
diminishes
whereas the quality of them improves um
and so some of it takes you actually
instead of finding a community sometimes
you have to make it
um also
so it can be lonely
and it can be alienating but it can also
if pursued with a genuine love it can
it can be liberating it can liberate you
and put you into real relationships with
real patterns and
real people in real ways so that's what
i have to say about that
what do you think that 80 year old you
would tell current you
what would 80 year old john tell
try to focus more
on the love you find in your
relationship and i don't i hope you me
no i don't mean just romantic love i'm
not excluding that but i don't mean just
romantic love
try to focus more on the love you find
in your relationships
than the fear that you find in your
relationships
that's a wonderful way to finish talking
about what's happening next
for you i know that i mean terrifyingly
discussing
the uh potential precipice at the end of
your
academic career which might
might come to fruition but hopefully
you'll be con sort of tempted to stay
on the audience side what can we expect
from you over the
remainder of 2021 i'm so i'm going to
start
filming tonight with greg enriquez chris
master pietro
uh the elusive i capital i uh
the elusive eye the nature and function
of the self uh trying to do sort of the
best cognitive science
on what is this thing we call the self
how does it work and how does it
function what is it how does it function
um and then hopefully when covett will
allow me
probably a 20 to 30 part series called
after socrates
where i'm going to go back to the
socratic practices
of authentic deal logos see how it
worked what was dialectic
how did it bring us into the flow state
of the logos
do that historical analysis and then do
a
structural scientific analysis and
participant observation because i've
already been doing it
of all these emerging authentic
discourse communities circling practices
and the empathy circling and you know
insight dialogue and inquiry
there is no coincidence that we have
this proliferation
of of practices that are designed to
reintegrate communication and communion
and transformation
together and so i want to take i want to
do the best historical analysis
of the socratic heritage follow it all
the way through all the people that came
after socrates
and so socrates and the stoix and the
epicureans and the neoplatonus and the
existentialists
right all of that so that's one sense of
after but also people who are taking
after socrates right now
who are trying to create right these
steal the culture bottom up
by creating new ways of entering into
the logos and then
if you'll allow me the pun put those two
into dialogue with each other
the history and the analysis and we've
you know
already published a book on well seeking
publication on a book
on this right now called internet or
dialogues where we have chris
chris matthew vietto and i we're editing
we've got all the people and this
well not all of them but a lot of people
in this community the people who are
both practicing it
and theorizing about it and trying to
put the two together that's hopefully
coming out this year after socrates is
going to be coming out
uh this year uh there'll still be more
more voices with the reiki
there'll be the uh like i said the
elusive eye
um and then after after after socrates
is done
i want to start working on uh i sort of
always had a trilogy in mind the third
series
uh the third sort of big big scope
theories
series is called the god beyond god
and the inventio of the sacred because
the latin word inventio means to
discover and to make
it means both of them together um
and so um those are the things that
uh john vicki is going to be working on
where should people go if they want to
be kept up to date with
what's happening they can follow me on
twitter um
they can subscribe on youtube channel uh
that would i'm also on linkedin um
but i don't use it but i through
hootsuite i sort of post on facebook
um so there's there's a bunch of places
um
but especially uh on twitter and youtube
that's
that's where you could most readily get
the information i do a monthly
live streamed q a on my youtube channel
um that's one the next one is actually
this friday
at 3 p.m eastern standard time if people
want to come on and ask questions
awesome all of that will be linked in
the show notes below john thank you i
really really love your work
i'm very very glad that i found it um
and yeah i'm looking forward to being
terrified and satisfied in equal measure
hopefully as i continue to dig deeper
into it
well thank you chris i really enjoyed
this um
yeah i just it was great and um
if you ever want to talk again i'd be
open to it
[Music]